So we have been talking about
implementation of access control and
the resources and request for
those resources and
we said well in Linux based systems,
resources look like files.
So let's actually see how the resources
are used and you know what
kind of calls we make for accessing them
and what happens during those calls.
So, first of all, of course,
resource has to be created.
So the process that creates
this resource is the owner.
That owner can have whatever set of
access rights they want to have.
In a Unix-like system, you probably
know the number of ways in which you can
create a file, for example.
So once a file exists and
we want to access it,
you do what is called open the file.
S this is sort of like
prepping the file.
If it doesn't exist,
then file gets created.
When you do that,
file has a name and mode here says,
do you want to read this file or
do you want to write it or execute it.
What are you opening it for?
How do you want to access it?
Once that file exists,
the first thing we do is open it.
When you open it the operating system
returns to you a descriptor which is
a small number, and we'll see what
the use of that is, but as a result
we'll see that to be able to access or
get the data that's in the file,
write it into the file, we're
going to need the file's descriptor.
So the descriptor comes when you
open the file, you prep it or
get it ready for access.
So a system call you make saying,
this is the file I want to access,
this is how I access it.
The operating system
prepares the file for
accessing, returns you this file
descriptor that you then hold on to.
So if you want to read this
file in the read call,
this is another system
call that you have.
You have to go to the system.
You specify what file
using a descriptor.
This is what was returned here.
It's a small number.
So this could be file for example.
If you're reading you are to specify
where the read data should be put,
how much data you are reading.
That's the buffer, and the size.
Data is going to come from the file.
Where is this data?
Well, the file we know, unless file
point or that points at the next
place from where your data is going to
come and it is advance that you read.
So whatever data follows the file,
current file pointer,
we are going to pull that data,
lays that in the buffer and
that's what the recall is going to do.
Similarly there's a write call, except
that the data flows in the opposite
direction, so the data is here then
it's going to go into the file.
And how much data,
that's what we specify in this call.
So an open is followed by one or
more read or writes.
And when you're done you close the file.
And once you close the file,
again the input
here is the descriptor that says
what file that you had open before.
Then this file we are basically telling
the system is that we're not going to
need to access it anymore.
So the system can,
if I'd set up some data structures,
it can essentially free
those up at that point.
A resource is a file.
Users have UID, we also talked about
group ID, and to access a resource,
this is what we basically have to go
through, file exists, they'll open it,
then then they have to say read or
write it, and then you close it.
If you forget to close it and
the process terminates,
it's implicitly closed, but
this is how a file gets used.